[Music]
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I am up Bernard hey welcome back
folks 2019 man first show of 2019 put
your hands together we made it country
still here at least California is
feeling great about things feeling
positive about 2019 but ladies and
gentlemen before we go any [ __ ]
further I want you to recognize the fact
recognize and respect the fact that
you're standing before greatness one of
us is a Writers Guild Award nominated
writer that's right a little bit late
and [ __ ] but they finally recognized my
ass for yoga hosers no lard marvelous
mark barnard a man who sits before you
every time we do this show and spits
wisdom about the art of writing
screenwriting script writing and
otherwise and whatnot finally had
somebody other than these [ __ ] drunks
recognized the fact that he knows what
the [ __ ] he's doing the Writers Guild
nominated what rocks Rock you're what
for best long form original series this
is Castle Rock in blu-ray form so in
honor of that I'm going to give away a
couple of DVD DVD [ __ ] spoil years yes
boxes spoilers man 35 millimeter cans in
the back film strips we can watch later
on they'll be a viewmaster presentation
what happens man to your life when
you're nominated for an award for it for
your [ __ ] field they make you pay for
tickets to the ceremonies what happens
are you sure there's the writers guild
and not the writers guild with a wide
ride hers guild lately I got an email
sec hey congratulations on your
nomination if you want to buy tickets in
the ceremony they're gonna cost you X
I'm like but the [ __ ] scam its I mean
it's a guild man I gotta get their dues
that's true literally so when is the
event the 17th of February who you up
against no I'm not sure you [ __ ] liar
oh my god you sit there in your bed at
night gonna [ __ ] hate that other [ __ ]
I swear to god you don't know no you
know what doesn't matter good Sun a
competitive joe paterno HBO's joe
paterno miniseries who wrote that I have
no idea I think it was David Mamet
wasn't it you're [ __ ] this is fun guys
thank you I don't know the road well so
wait you guys are a series that was a
movie what's the category again
long-form original so it seems like you
guys got unfair odd you get like ten
bites at the Apple they had one for two
hours you got eight more hours you
should win the award just four more
that's what I figured we're gonna do and
pretty much well I don't know if you're
gonna win the award but I have an award
to present you it's your very own Batman
Beyond crest that's right mark there you
are a jersey to put it on or you can put
it on back of a leather jacket or a
denim jacket the [ __ ] I'm gonna get it
framed and then put on a chain so I can
Flavor Flav this oh my god genius I
never thought of that
that's gonna be awesome thank you how
were your holidays it all changed when
he went back home nobody else seemed to
know and I just kept on breezing into
rooms expecting like rose petals on the
ground like [ __ ] Prince Akeem like oh
he's yeah
none of that [ __ ] man it was just hey
good to see again you get to sleep in
that room thanks mom that's the writers
room ah it was good it was really busy I
was back east
seeing my wife's family and my family
and so 10 days of jockeying between
people asking me why I don't have a job
it's always fun but you tell him you
were nominated for an award
yeah but where's your job I'm like well
I just rapped redstone just rapped at
the end of December and so I'm gainfully
unemployed until I find the next job
like when's that gonna be I don't know
could be February it could be June no
like that's not a way to live you have a
family how do you six months without
work that's okay that's how we do it you
should just sit there and be like you
know you're really turning me around
here where's the nearest Duncan I'm
going it's all about responsibility
don't they know that you're an artist
and you're irresponsible and you only
care about yourself well now I made that
abundantly clear [ __ ] these people and
they're on their own but it's good it
was good I got to eat all of the East
Coast food that I miss mmm and so I
gained like 10 pounds in the process as
you can see I'm not pleasantly plump I
don't see I'm a big beautiful woman now
but bvw action or I got the I got the
third seed on thick usually you just get
to sees I went for the third that's it
you got baggies yeah I was here for the
holidays we didn't really do much for
hung out here and then I had battle on
on New Year's Eve but this week I just
got done with Saturday right now
yesterday in the afternoon I got done
directing my third episode of the
Goldbergs yes I showed them how to make
that [ __ ] show for once it's a
ridiculous job they can make that show
very well without me and do many many
times over and over but they let me go
and hang out and I'm always reminded you
know before I go I'm like ah ma'am
they don't need me and then one on there
I don't care if they don't need me
because you're getting the watch really
incredibly talented folks just genius
level comedic talents
ad-lib within a small box right they
can't just [ __ ] say anything they
want they got to say a TV worthy and
like legit make me laugh so like you
know it's a job that you leave and like
I got some legit belly laughs like
throughout the day it was real fun to
watch them do their thing but they
realize I've said a million times they
don't need a director let alone me
anybody could just be like action cut
like it's really kind of controlled by
the writers and rightfully so it's like
a rider's paradise but I was supposed to
direct an episode the third episode the
day after I shot my Showtime special in
Glendale back in February 25th the night
I had the heart attack yeah you're busy
yes so I was like I shot the special
that night I'm supposed to shoot - but
then [ __ ] my heart went [ __ ] you and
so we didn't shoot the second one and
then I was supposed to go to work the
next morning on the Goldbergs so they
had to tell him that like he's not
coming and look why and the like he
almost died they're like oh all right so
I haven't been able to return since like
just schedule-wise so this is my first
time was my first time going back and
when I got there I was like hey man I
can't wait like this is gonna be fun I
said but we'll wait until the end of the
day to test my theory that it was you
[ __ ] that gave me the heart attack
and [ __ ] so made it all the way through
no heart attack had a good time made a
really funny episode they did I watched
like a dirty little cook on the corner
and [ __ ] it's kind of like what
directing TV feels like you just sit
there and [ __ ] bark [ __ ] from the
corner like do it faster
yeah say that again kiss her now kiss
the other one like that's not in the
script
oh yeah all right too far Jeff Garlin it
was it was funny I was good week and
[ __ ] so I'm all done with that this week
I got some interviews to do isn't
podcasting then I go away for a few days
to do some gigs on the road going to
Phoenix with Ralph to do Babylon and
then I'm also going to Canada man
Saskatchewan whoo three dates in
Saskatchewan in Canada
that's right man you ain't kidding I
told telling somebody today I was a car
dealership for the kid and the guy was
like it's a sketchy one that's one of
the lesser known provinces and then we
gave to that at Sundance man going up to
Sundance interview people again stick
microphones in the face of talented
people and be like tell me how to do it
and [ __ ] like how is IMDB gonna get a
boat to Sundance fits Corallo style [ __ ]
right up the hill they they've they've
teamed up with Acura this year and where
there were these igloo type tents that
they build that we're gonna be
interviewing people I saw the list of
people man it's [ __ ] nuts there's a
lot of folks that we're talking to and
it's like the third or fourth year I
think we're doing it so far so good man
they'll be fun awesome then after that
off to make a movie that's more on that
but Bay before we speaking of movies
before we go any further because of what
we do May I don't know if I assume it's
the same for you but I never really
asked because of this job do you get
sent [ __ ] took that promotes other [ __ ]
I know no they said you should yeah as
your fancy I guess they don't send so
much [ __ ] for the dude next to fancy
unless your fancy adjacent unless you're
captain fancy from NYPD blue maybe that
guy's [ __ ] I don't get anything I've
been sent some [ __ ] and I was like oh
[ __ ] like I might as well talk about it
on the show they sent it to me for
promotion so I might as well promote it
but it is kind of cool and it also makes
you go
holy [ __ ] how much did they spend on
this [ __ ] cuz the vase is that one to me
and they didn't send one of you I don't
know who the [ __ ] else they sent it to
and [ __ ] there must be hundreds of these
things out there this first of all came
from the folks that did the venom motion
picture they had some sort of team up
with brisk iced tea so brisk is in like
this superhero movie business they did
that big [ __ ] black panther Samsung
tablets and iced tea cans they must have
made money with Marvel and keep like
doing these things but but this is
different Marvel than that Marvel right
like that was black panther this was
Sony Marvel for venom so I didn't see
the movie mark did you reviewed it and
then finally I saw the movie over
Christmas break it came on iTunes and
one morning I was up and blaze and I was
like [ __ ] it let's watch vanaman [ __ ]
thank God I was stoned because like it
really makes sense if your stone did
[ __ ] it was a fun ride blaze does
that remember you like [ __ ] this movie
and so however - I was high and I was
like no no not yet don't [ __ ] it and
kept watching my only complaint was it
took an hour to get to venom but Tom
Hardy is so fascinating to watch that
like you know I said like I'd watch him
read the [ __ ] phone book before like
I was fine to watch him walk around and
just make [ __ ] up as he went along
that's what it seemed like the
performance was literally him just going
like I'm gonna do this imma try this and
I was OLM always constantly scene after
scene impressed by the balls of this
movie
like you know you've got templates out
there like Marvel makes all these
amazing comic book movies you even know
how not to do it based on some of the DC
[ __ ] and whatnot so you know the x-men
have been doing it for years like there
are wait there's a way to make up
superhero movie and this didn't do it it
didn't refuse to every step of the way
and it refused to like take the last
step and be in r-rated movie they tried
to have their cake and eat it but like
the whole time I was watching the movie
I was like [ __ ] I respect this careers
will be lost and it wasn't the case
everyone got rewarded the movie made
like eight hundred million dollars in
[ __ ] they're gonna make a [ __ ] sequel
so fortune favors the bold man they like
really swung for the [ __ ] fences
another one of these movies that like
all we heard about was like troubled
it's in trouble this movie's piece of
[ __ ] and whatnot and it came out and
everybody was like good enough and his
[ __ ] likes the movie man apparently
they loved it overseas so I I enjoyed by
the time venom showed up I was like
right the [ __ ] on more of this less of
the first hour and then and then when
you know Michelle Williams does what she
does in the move I mean like they got
crazy great actors across the board I
don't understand how but but really
though oh yeah look come on man
everybody wants to be in a [ __ ] sure
everyone wants to be in a superhero
movie it's so nice oh they'll probably
throw some bucks around I'm sure if
there were people that don't know the
character in the cast if there's still
some [ __ ] people out there though like
do comics like and somebody in their
life didn't explain this is a good thing
to [ __ ] do you know they know someone
with a kid who's like oh my god Marvel
you should do it and [ __ ] so they wind
up with a really great [ __ ] cast
classy [ __ ] actors that whole step of
the way even though the movie at times
makes very little sense you've just it's
held together by great performances like
and again I was blaze give it you know
that was well so I was in for the whole
[ __ ] ride and then by the end of it I
was like Ollie shed carnage so I you
know good times you know at least if
you're watching it December 30th at 4:00
in the morning and the blade
I don't think they were thinking of me
when they made it but [ __ ] they had man
[ __ ] so anyway this was something that
they sent along as their premium came in
a box that says fragile handle with
care' open immediately and it has a
bunch of [ __ ] in here from the life
foundation which if you've seen the
movie there's somehow responds well
they're the ones that found the Venom
symbiote symbiotic Simba Simba what did
she say
Simba this it's from the Life Foundation
attention kevin smith the letter nice
personalized and yeah and I felt really
important and and as his life foundation
training center curated by brisk and
that's when I started to be like is this
a commercial discovery of symbiosis the
office of dr. Carlton Drake reference
number of Bob Loblaw see venom attention
Kevin Smith congratulations you have
been hand selected by dr. Carlton Drake
and the life foundation to take part in
an exclusive symbiote examination you
have been identified as a possible match
an outstanding candidate across all
laboratory measurement standards host
capability social engagement ability
connect with others they want my [ __ ]
vote yes they want your followers yeah
no duh symbiosis and then they explain
to me what they are I felt like writing
them back could be like let me tell you
what [ __ ] is in biotech we are
sending you this specimen for your own
inspection please handle with care and
at your own risk regards the office of
dr. Carlton Drake so this is what every
would be careful there's a thing inside
says brisk my van like look at the money
what is it hold on of this you okay oh
yeah is heavy
I feel like Raiders of the Lost Ark
[Music]
keep your eyes shut
what the [ __ ] and more poorly why the
[ __ ] it looks like one of those things
like when in the 70s you were putting
money in the bank and you put I could
put it into the tube and it goes up the
pneumatic chute but more importantly
like somebody [ __ ] spent some money
on this man I mean I know it's just a
bunch of stickers that say brisk and
Veneman Life Foundation but like these
plastic containers which will never die
for half a million years but what I'm
pretty [ __ ] well made it is let's see
let's dare we open it let's the
symbiotic jump out is just a [ __ ]
canister for iced tea I mean and it's
hard to get the iced tea out though it's
for a brisk iced tea symbiotic dark
cherry limeade it's only 60 calories so
apparently you know brisk do we take a
sip no no apparently the risk God in a
business or you know sponsorship deal
with good folks at Sony and put this out
there in the world and you know it's a
container I guess kind of looks like the
one they had in the movie and [ __ ] like
that
now I will never play with this what is
but it's not even a thing it's just a
[ __ ] canister I know but somewhere
there must be somebody's like I [ __ ]
love and I was [ __ ] like 100 million
of that 800 million and [ __ ] and I'm
hoping they're at the bar tonight and
they could walk home with it who wants
this said no you in the back your loved
ones here come on up you got to tell me
why yeah listen this is not a
suppository I mean it's gotta be useful
for some [ __ ] right suppose your name
son my name is Tanner everyone give it
up for Tanner
I know you look familiar in the mirror
why would I'm not judging you but why
why would you want this and be honest
because I have a friend who's who has a
venom tattoo and I think he would really
like this [ __ ] nicer you're a good
friend you win man
Charlie you win the Chocolate Factory
take this the case with all the looking
branding yeah man make sure and then he
gets the branding throw that in there
I mean it's brisk it worked man this is
going to make someone very happy thank
you for taking out anyway it is it is
this weird thing of like just how
low-rent venom is is a movie is that
that's the [ __ ] merch that they give
away like for Black Panther you got a
tablet you got a drinks that have
people's faces on it you got the fancy
Eskimo your beads which I still wear and
make my people nervous but it's just a
[ __ ] case yeah what do you do it you
won't stop [ __ ] on venom will you
even when it comes to their premium I
start [ __ ] on Aquaman well before
you talk about that DC movie let's talk
about another DC movie that they sent me
another premium yeah this is the
official Shazam ugly Christmas sweater
it comes with a batteries so you put it
in and then of course the Shazam lights
up smarter it also comes with
instructions that tells you how to wash
it because it's got electronics and
appreciate you know once again man
somebody spent some [ __ ] money on
this and you know they sent it to me I'm
pre-sold so you know hopefully this
sells a few more tickets for him because
that was there in ten but I'm never it's
safe to say I'm never gonna wear this
are you sure
um even if I love the movie and honestly
I look like a [ __ ] stupid but like
welled up watching the trailer I'm
probably never gonna wear this but
somebody in this room is a [ __ ] huge
Shazam fan or knows one or knows a small
child that could wear a men's XL shirt
or if you look at ears get up here man
give it up for caddy or she wins the
[ __ ] Shazam shirt see my I was gonna
see if anybody knew what this Shazam
stood for isn't it Socrates Hercules
wisdom of Solomon Solomon strength of
Hercules yes
something of a Adonis or Ares not war
Adonis what is it stamina that lists
stamina that was something of Zeus
something of a and then mercury so you
don't even know I don't know they didn't
send it to me I just wanted to know that
anybody else knew because I'm in the
dark on Shazam all right now that we've
promoted their movie and everyone goes
seizures and when it happens if you're a
comic book fan you should that being
said I reviewed Aquaman very favorably
was it favorite I enjoyed it yeah my
review I talked about how much I enjoyed
the movie
I did I did look I'm not gonna [ __ ] on
this company when they start making
steps in the right direction that's true
you know what I'm saying like it was
easy to be like [ __ ] what are you doing
with Justice League and [ __ ] like that
but that there if this movie has any
fault whatsoever it's that it has too
much [ __ ] movie and that should never
be considered a fault that's somebody
who's trying I'm watching Aquaman and we
watched it together was equivalent to
like [ __ ] somebody blowing you you
come and they keep [ __ ] going you
look we're you know yes it's [ __ ]
amazing but holy [ __ ] it hurts after a
while and so you know I I can never I
can't
carp or crap on the movie or anything
like that I love that they James through
in everything the ethos seemed to be we
don't know if we're ever gonna get a
shot at making another one of these how
many [ __ ] Aquaman movies are gonna
make let us make let's let's just
[ __ ] spend it all man push all in and
[ __ ] so much so they're like we're out
of villains here like take them all on
the first movie we'll make up new ones
like and it worked they they've been
rewarded financially then they made a
billion [ __ ] dollars worldwide so I
get I'm happy for them I give it up to
them hopefully now though like alright
we get it we'll make movies that people
enjoy movies that feel like comic-book
movies yeah I'm not like funeral dirge
does that move I've spoken a lot of
people like I want to work on a
Goldbergs and there's some people on set
who were like what you think Aquaman and
stuff and heard various opinions about
the movie so but my point was always
like view that movie through the prism
of a child like 9 years old oh my god
that would be your [ __ ] and everybody
was like my little cousin my son my
grandson
they [ __ ] loved it my granddaughter
my grant niece whatever the [ __ ] like
everyone knew a kid that loved the movie
and I'm like that's who it's [ __ ] for
at the end of the day
and like if you get anything out of it
like good that's that's fun it's
escapism and [ __ ] but it's not meant to
make you like change your life it's just
like we we did Aquaman and we didn't
[ __ ] up give us money and that's pretty
much what it said on the poster and they
were rewarded with the money I gave them
mine I went back and saw it again Wow
you I did not go back and see it again
listen I do yeah I paved the road now
you could say pave the road I do agree
with with one sentiment for sure which
is it is the most Aquaman movie you're
ever going to get oh and they do not sit
all the aqua it's all the Aquaman and it
never it's never afraid to be an Aquaman
movie yeah which you can say that Man of
Steel is a little afraid to be a
Superman movie oh my god so true you can
say that that you know Batman V Superman
is afraid to be a Batman or an
entertaining movie his words not mine
his words not [ __ ] I've watched that
I'm walking that back I've watched that
movie so many times I do find it
puzzling ly entertaining beside myself
how did you make this so bad it's not so
much that I'm just like every time I
watch them like no it's gonna [ __ ]
kick in right now now now credits [ __ ]
you know but I'm there for it man I'm
there for it but I you know I think
Aquaman is what they should be doing
taking big swings with [ __ ] that's not
interconnected that's got a lot of
imagination they conquered the seven
seas before Marvel did Marvel could have
with like no more if they had the rights
I don't even think they have the rights
don't see it but the way Marvel took
over space with guardians of the galaxy
and DC had a chance they beat him there
with Green Lantern and everyone was like
oh and then guardians of the galaxy
everyone was like ah
so DC dove into the ocean first and now
it's theirs they could make a bunch of
these [ __ ] undersea movies and [ __ ]
yeah and they probably will as long as
they have Jason Momoa in them yeah
because like that dude is legit
fascinating to watch yes like he's he's
trying so [ __ ] hard he really is and
succeeded through sheer force of will
does he make that character engaging
because
the character as written is not really
like I found myself in that movie way
more invested in in black panther sure
all the time black man black mana yeah
all day in his parents all day but like
what does the parents Aquaman yeah yeah
you know the emotional resonance of that
movie is his parents getting back
together again at the end of it right
that's the first time you actually feel
something for real
we Jesus but yeah like I there's there's
two things that I want out of a heroic
story because I want your hero to change
over the course of the story so that
what he does at the Yankee could not
have done at the beginning is really
hard it's carved out of wood it feels
like this carved out of wood who's Jesus
who's Lord is this 3d printed there's
your own personal Jesus I'm gonna go
home now my job here is done
it's beautifully gift what are these
holy should I see me and my kid and
Stanley yeah oh oh that's beautiful
there's a photo of me and the kid and
Stanley from from that lady from San
Diego years ago and you plug it in and
it glows you made this stand up man take
credit for this [ __ ] that's cool
say hello to the folks at home
what's your name concert Ryan Miller
Ryan Miller won't give it up for Ryan
good job while I show these off tell the
story of what they are tell them well I
decided to make something for Kevin for
Jay Mewes and one for mark each one's a
3d printed little pain so when you see
it just without light it just looks like
a 3d print and then when you put it up
to the light an actual picture comes out
that's awesome so so that one's marks
that's amazing I get to keep these ones
from mark this one's for Jay and that
one's for you oh my god these are
incredibly [ __ ] sweet and I didn't
bring you anything oh you know what I
did
do you like weed this right here is a
rolling tray and on it is the Jersey
brother hood local card the dealer tweed
card from Jay and Silent Bob strike back
this is made by the good folks at famous
brands we make stuff with them pipes and
[ __ ] like that it's not necessarily weed
oriented but [ __ ] that's why I roll
along so here you go thank you thank you
brushing trading is beautiful man thank
you
we got [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] I'll go man
continue about our cool man my thread is
all ruined now is all what no okay
here's the thing okay really quickly yes
when I watch a movie like Star Wars like
the matrix like Purple Rain yes you're
gonna use Purple Rain to indite Aquaman
I absolutely will oh I gotta hear this
go because the kid in Purple Rain at the
beginning of that movie yeah he can't
talk to sharks he cannot talk to sharks
but that is not that he could not have
at the beginning that movie written
Purple Rain he was not solvable race on
for the rain right he could not have
done you know Bay me I'm a star he could
not have made up with Apollonia he had
to go through [ __ ] to be the person he
is by the time that movie ends mind you
one of those things was abused his
girlfriend yes he's an awful human being
one of those it was the 80s his father
has to kill himself Aquaman Arthur curry
is the same person from the beginning of
that movie as he is at the end of a
movie he doesn't learn anything about
himself over the course of it and the
guy who you see in a bar beating up
other dudes or taken smiling [ __ ]
selfies with him the same guy that
defeats Orem at the end he doesn't learn
anything over the course of that movie
Luke Skywalker learns to trust the
[ __ ] force right like neo learns how
to [ __ ] bend time and absorb damage
and be the one right Aquaman is Aquaman
throughout so he just starts he starts
and finishes as and like there's there's
something kind of Hollow
occasionally how about a hero who
doesn't learn anything over the course
of that and he doesn't have a want in
that movie he doesn't have a want of the
movie answers for him Luke Skywalker
wants to be a wants to leave that planet
and take part in a larger world mm-hmm
neo wants to find out why his life is so
hollow and what is the matrix the kid
wants to be a [ __ ] star and so but
over the course of that movie the movie
answers that need that movie gives him
that thing
what does Arthur curry want does he want
a home well he's got a really good
relation with his dad he knows his mom
as he knows where his home is he knows
all of it he's rejected it but he knows
it
is it do I want to be the king of
Atlantis not really he keeps wanting to
push that away in a return maybe he
wants to reunite with his mom but he
doesn't know she's alive until he sees
her again so because he has no want the
movie gives nothing to give him to
reward him for enduring what he has to
endure which isn't very much and so as
kaleidoscopic as a movie is as much fun
as it is occasionally it doesn't it
never harmonized never it never rhymed
with itself and never gave you something
more solid at the base to make all of
the stuff at the surface worthwhile may
I rebut your argument rebut away my
friend armored [ __ ] shark mother
[ __ ] sharks with armored man
weaponized [ __ ] sharks Yeah right
look I hear I hear you and I've stood
next to you long enough doing the show
that when we watch the movie even I was
thinking like Marc's gonna be mad this
[ __ ] ain't got a journey got no
goddamn [ __ ] so I knew we'd be back here
and stuff and you're probably right like
at the end of the day that's generally
what's needed blur the movie does enough
so well yes that it's it's next to
Wonder Woman it's my favorite of the I
guess Snyder verse of these things of
the post
Nolan versus post Nolan first this is
easily my favorite where is it compared
to the Nolan stuff I mean the Nolan
stuff is still the high bar yeah it's
like B plus a plus B plus B okay a minus
a plus B plus feels about right where we
can put Aquaman up commands like a solid
B minus like it's super entertaining
it's way above a passing grade yeah but
it's just it's a little hollow at its
core place they studied for the test but
just enough just enough
hence the Biman tends to be - you know
GPA like you're still improving over the
other stuff but I any you know a fault
that I may have had with it absolutely
let go in the face of the fact that they
included that black mantas storyline and
gave it an arc we saw the whole birth of
the origin that leave Ellen I know what
that guy wants yeah yeah I know exactly
what he wants I know what drives him I
know he loses something over the course
of it that prompts him to become a more
fully realized villain right what the
Carey doesn't lose anything he just just
like swans in and woo do you think yeah
he is he's the king of the broche in yo
I enjoyed it I wonder what they'll do
next though just like Wonder Woman I
really enjoyed it now as I got man what
do you do next and when they said
cheetah and Kristen Wiig I was like
[ __ ] take all my money I'm so
interesting then they're like it's in
the 80s I'm like Jesus you [ __ ] had
me at hello
so I am so [ __ ] curious though where
they go next no filmmaker wants to hear
that he makes something like that look
like it took forever and all the money's
in the world and [ __ ] and my first thing
is like uh what are you gonna do next
but I am kind of curious where they go I
mean obviously it'll include Black Manta
again because he spoilers is still alive
also I bet you lots of it is underwater
yeah he's not going to space although
there are they kind of RAD though he did
go to the desert though which we wanted
I did not on one of the shows you were
like I wish they would put him in
[ __ ] the desert and they never show
like the the four months where they walk
out of the desert because they jumped
out of a plane and don't have any money
and they're in the desert
and then they're not that's right fly I
I [ __ ] here that's what I look for my
Aquaman realism I'm looking for the
travelogue man um like I said just
passed a billion bucks so holy crap
no I mean big win for them did Wonder
Woman hit a billion Oh Wonder Woman Lois
I was like hey 70 something so this is
[ __ ] massive yeah huge and a big sigh
of relief too because now it means
they'll you know keep going I we can do
a comic book movie let's do another one
let's do another one yeah and it speaks
to the idea that if you it's the
Deadpool right it's the make the most
movie that's like the thing that you can
yeah be true to what it is and people
will come yes let me Deadpool is a
better movie but Deadpool is the most
Deadpool movie were ever gonna get this
is the most Aquaman moving you're ever
gonna get oh it was [ __ ] soaking wet
it was a seafood buffet it was like
going a Red Lobster yeah and you know
buffet night all right
man [ __ ] all that I said all we got up
front for it I got one last thing yeah
did I tell you that I started another
podcast but I'm cheating on you with
somebody else you chose to tell me in
public in front of people so that I
wouldn't go ape [ __ ] man you're Bob
sugar and me you [ __ ]
I know it's like when you get fired and
they bring security up to make sure that
you don't just wild out on people
I am sending I've somewhat aware this
this the one that you're doing with what
was her name on the show
caprica-six six yeah Tricia Helfer
uh-huh yeah you talked about a while
back I'm glad to know this happened I
did yeah the Battlestar Galactica I am
great name thank you I'm co-hosting with
Tricia Helfer and we are watching every
episode of Battlestar Galactica week by
week by week by week by week what a hard
job it's the worst because a she's hard
to look at and be not at all charming
and see I hate the show
for me it would go number one Canadian
number two she was on the show
number three Canadian just to be able to
talk to a Canadian every [ __ ] week on
a podcast is so sweet yeah like she's
got a house full of cats and I'm
allergic to cats
and so we caught her house and every
time I show up there's like a little
clarity on a dish waiting for me because
she knows that if she doesn't do that I
will die quickly until one day it's not
a claritin and you're just like what's
happening to me starts rubbing cats all
over here you thought that was funny
[ __ ]
how long you been doing it what episode
young we we drop every episode on
Tuesdays no I just did 102 so we did two
episodes for the miniseries and then the
first one 33 second one water and then
we do the third one best steal day next
Tuesday I loved that show so [ __ ]
good one of my favorite TV moments of
all time is the Galactica and what
season I think is the last season well
maybe this season before the last season
when the Galactica drops does the jump
right into the planet's surface and
dropping off oh my god it's [ __ ]
breathtaking like you know they do
Lightspeed jumps in the show and what do
they call it there was a name the FTL
the FTL drive doesn't like and they
would [ __ ] you know turn a key and
then they would do their version of what
do they call and warp drive and Star
Trek and [ __ ] Lightspeed in Star Wars
so it would show you know go leave one
place and then show up in another that's
how fast it was gone you've seen the
concept before but they if they did this
jump close to the surface they had to
like save all these people and stuff
that were on the planet New Caprica that
what it was
yes and in order to get them in and get
the fighters out real low the fighter
ships they dialed up the FT I'm gonna
cry talking about it was so [ __ ] I
remember sitting there but my wife was
next to me going like what are they
doing it's like shut the [ __ ] up
and I was so dialed in and she was like
what no I was like nobody's ever done
this work I if they're doing what I
think you're gonna do is nobody's ever
[ __ ] done oh my god they [ __ ] dead
you know and she put her excitement mics
haven't caught up to her she was like so
excited she even know what the [ __ ] was
going on and chin the ship dialed their
FTL and dropped into the lower
atmosphere of the planet just [ __ ]
appeared 200 you know what maybe even if
I get 10,000 feet the where where a
plane would be taking off and and it's
falling because it can't fight the
gravity so you just see the heat bloom
on the bottom of it and it crashes
throws the ground just long enough to
let the fighters out all the fighters
are [ __ ] launched you have and just
before it's about that the planet they
[ __ ] jump again oh it's so [ __ ]
awesome that episode you don't get to
for like two years we'll have you on for
that listen kid really wants to talk
about this claim that really well that's
awesome where can they find uh wherever
if your local podcaster E is found Apple
iTunes podcast whatever the call on this
day Battlestar Galactica Battlestar
Galactica excellent [ __ ] name give it
up for mark man he's a multi media maven
so much fun
alright we got news we got news mark
barnard Ihnen his former life his secret
identity prior to this existence prior
to becoming a writers guild nominated
writer used to write the news cover the
news man names a gumshoe he was a guy
with a press card and the [ __ ] bill
of a Stetson him what no that's right so
we turned to mark every week and we say
go to the Internet and pull up all the
news and steal the news other people
have reported tell us and it keeps him
warm it keeps that old that old
journalist again really does and then I
start talking like I'm in some 30s movie
hey what do you got
what's the news what's a skinny Oh mark
has a bunch of news first give it up for
Mark Barnard he found the news
News News News News News all right
hey so you know that Disney Fox deal is
happening for real the Disney Fox deal
as we enter 2019 long-rumored and we all
thought it was a done deal yes they're
now acknowledging oh yeah that is for
real there are no acknowledging this for
real and there's beginning to be a
little bit of fallout from the deal not
the least of which is that rumor has it
that most of the Fox x-men spin-off
movies yeah are kind of dead weight
explained so every so what about Zara
Phoenix Dark Phoenix will come out this
year new that's still happening we can't
stop it we can't you you cannot get in
the way of the Dark Phoenix yeah Dark
Phoenix and me mutants are happening
okay for sure they're already shot
they're being waiting the deads whole
spin-offs x-force
x-force gambit Kitty Pryde Doctor Doom
even most of those things are gonna fall
by the wayside all the toys go back to
Kevin Feige all the toys all of Fox's
toys go back to Kevin Feige I'm happy
that makes me happy man they're in the
right hands and now he's got it that
means he gets back Marvel's first family
the Fantastic Four so fantastic we may
finally get the Fantastic Four movie
that we've all been dreaming about and
stuff something that really captures our
imagination in the bars hi because Brad
Bird made that movie it was called The
Incredibles so they gotta figure out a
way to [ __ ] and do it again but if
anybody can it's fact Kevin Feige
yeah I believe in that dude yes they do
doesn't let me down yet man like trying
to think of the Marvel movie though it
was like is that right dark Thor dark
world if that's the [ __ ] worst thing
you ever did to humanity your ass ain't
in my book yeah it's not even that bad
no but yeah so Channing Tatum will not
get to play gambit [ __ ]
unless Kevin Feige is like hey Chang do
you want to play it gambit yeah no I
mean I like Channing Tatum but I wasn't
like oh I got to see that [ __ ] movie
what else what goes by the x-force is
the only one I'm like really I'd [ __ ]
still yeah like make that if I was
Disney yeah bro I gonna do with Deadpool
I mean how they're gonna handle it I
feel like Deadpool stays Deadpool I
think Fox at the end of the day will be
its own imprint in a way at Disney and
and that's where they beliefs the sort
of adult versions of drama and action
and that sort of thing so there'll
always be a fox owned by Disney and
we'll totally get a rated-r Deadpool 3
because why would you not make that
money it's true fair enough I mean
Miramax was owned by Disney at one point
it's true that's why I have a career all
right yeah that's well that's great news
it seems like redundant news we knew
this over yeah we didn't know yet that
like x-force was probably just not gonna
happen
yeah every guest we could now there been
like yeah you guessed right focus right
did I see the pg-13 Deadpool cow tears
asks I did not did you once upon a
Deadpool I only watch that [ __ ] if it's
on like basic cable and I come across it
on a Saturday afternoon like yeah I
watched die hard on FX cuz why the [ __ ]
not it's Saturday at 4 o'clock and I not
doing anything
I would not on purpose watch the edited
version of something but they did more
than edited they put in all new stuff
with Fred Savage right it's its own
unique journey everyone keeps telling me
I'll watch him when he hits iTunes but I
was not going back to the theater I was
like fool me once shame on you fool me
twice with less cursing shame the [ __ ]
on now but I'll buy it man I happily
when I could watch it home for in the
morning smoke and we amazing Fred Savage
and everything this is such a great idea
I can't believe we live in a world where
like that's something you would like
maybe do on Funny or Die and they're
like no let's look do it for real in a
movie theater so that's kind of cool it
works that's high praise and four
o'clock on a Saturday when it's on TNT
you all right what else you got you know
they're making a new dune movie yeah
it's our boy who did getting a rival use
that name done you who did the Blade
Runner 2049 it was called and he did
something else I really liked as well
what is it I mentioned that one already
it was before arrival he did something
he did a Sicario Sicario prisoners that
I loved as well but so he's making a do
movie and they're casting it out he's
doing doing he's doing as a feature not
serious okay one movie one movie
whatever probably the first of a trilogy
right right but Timothy sha'lame is
playing the unpolished reading all the
tradies
oh my god that made my dick heart a
little bit really that's kind of cool
yeah
all right I'm [ __ ] in well I was
already in because I like ten even youth
but like that shall amaze Paul Atreides
the sleeper has awakened sleeper will
awaken stay out [ __ ] peaches you're
getting [ __ ] stellan skarsgård is
playing Baron Harkonnen hold on stellan
skarsgård is that the guy who with the
suit that's the guy with all the scars
and the lefty suit your skin is like
music to me bad right yeah that guy
felons scars good Dave Bautista was just
cast as the Beast Rabanne oh [ __ ] man
good which is pretty [ __ ] bad he'll
probably get a bigger role this time
around I would think so they have yet to
cast fade yeah which was played by sting
yeah first remember ibly sting in a
space bikini do you think we need to get
another rock star to do it no and I'm
not familiar did you read the books I
did we do books he's fade a much bigger
character than he was in the movie he
gets to be a bigger character I mean if
I remember correctly they don't kill him
at the beginning of the first book the
movie it was Star Wars influenced by
dune was who is fade in Star Wars it's
more that like Tatooine is basically
eraqus and if you watch Star Wars you
can see that they I think when the
droids first show up they're walking by
the giant skeleton of what is ultimately
supposed to be
the maker worms Oh get out of here yeah
they reference that yeah that's what
that was mhm and the spice all that
[ __ ] spice all that [ __ ] time
alright I'm on board for that movie
can't wait yeah
so dave bautista all good [ __ ]
additions to that and Rebecca Ferguson I
spoke to him about it I think San Diego
comic-con and you know he was like look
I love the David Lynch thing I like the
miniseries he's going but like I loved
the books and I still haven't seen the
book and I'm gonna do the book so it's
got a vision man and a talent to back it
up
speaking of Disney and Marvel they are
moving forward on the vision and Scarlet
Witch show that's happening that's
actually they hire star they show their
work
who's the showrunner a woman named Jack
Schaeffer who co-wrote Captain Marvel oh
great they stayed within the the
cinematic stable totally that's what the
word is that they're kind of not gonna
run that like a TV is certainly not
being run through the Marvel TV division
that's being run through Marvel right
was like five he's in charge of this why
he's ever seen all of that stuff they
are doing a Loki show they are doing a
Winter Soldier and Falcon show Wow and
they apparently this is on Disney some
deeds a-plus-plus Bruce Disney produced
and there's also a rumor that they're
gonna do a lady SIF show in the thaw
reverse in the thaw reverse she lived
she wasn't in writing Rock she wasn't
Ragnarok I think only because of his
scheduling problem not that she had died
before then so maybe that's what the
shows about
yeah or maybe it's unclear if it's gonna
be taking place before the [ __ ] snap
or after or I think the Loki show is set
before the snap clearly my but it's more
him and in his case he had there was a
different kind of snap for him but I
think it's more like they're gonna very
witty wild very nice John thank you
but I think he's it's more like Thor
recounting his own greatest hits that's
what I think Lady SIF would be I think
that's what the Loki show is sorry
lokiry county's greatest hits oh I'm
going oh that makes right cuz he is full
of himself as he is
I'm in I'm in for all that man that
sounds [ __ ] delicious and if it's
coming right from Marvel Cinematic
Universe you know I'm not the world's
biggest Lady SIF fan but I'll [ __ ]
watch that show watch the [ __ ] out I'll
watch it twice and I'll get high and
watch it again
can't wait take all my time away man I
want to finish these shows realize I'm
90 drop dead there you go
that's my plan there'll be more there's
more that's true they'll be more yeah
they're not gonna leave anything
untouched are they I'm not sure I don't
doubt this and you might have this in
your news but we're getting another
coming to America my next [ __ ] thing
I am all for this man I love those
characters I love that Eddie Murphy
wants to go be funny and play around I
happily go back to that universe those
people still alive
I know do you want to know the plot you
know it yeah let me guess okay if it's
coming to America he can't come back
he's not gonna be divorced from the
Queen because that would ruin the story
so must be a second generation involved
maybe the kid is coming here maybe Eddie
Murphy is now the James Earl Jones role
and there's a younger a key more
probably in this day and age it'll be a
princess who does not want to marry and
is coming to America to find her prince
please tell me I'm right no but close
okay there's also not what I wanted it
to be okay which was this was your idea
my idea would have been obviously we've
been working on sequels in our hearts
for years I know like brokering the
Peace Accords between zamunda and
Wakanda it is not that what is it in the
sequel Hakeem learns about a long-lost
son and must return to America to wait
his long awesome his long-lost son or a
long-lost son so maybe his brother could
be his brother could be I guess a nephew
maybe his dad got busy if it's a brother
it could be Kevin Hart
you know what I'm saying I'm just trying
to get asked real quick like who would
you if you're casting if the studio
person you're like look we got any
Murphy man we got coming to America too
and that should be enough but I'm gonna
juice how do we guild this lily annular
Kevin Hart so that would be my guess
so he finds out about a long-lost son
and must return to America to meet his
unlikely heir to the throne of Zamunda
so it is his son and not a son so one of
the girls in the bath the Royal dick is
clean your highness like who that were
HAP's did he have sex in America other
than we saw a bunch of first dates we
don't know where those first dates went
we know Semmy had lots of sex he had
lots of first and second dates alright
and that's the story the intention is to
bring back the original cast which
includes Arsenio Hall yay John Amos and
James Earl Jones I'm on board for all of
this
remembering that if we don't have coming
to America you probably never have James
Earl Jones in the Lion King you know one
happened before the other one inspired
the other like in everyone's like
[ __ ] it's true so it's an important
movie it's not disposable but it's
[ __ ] it's a wonderful movie the big
thing when that movie came out was
remember the controversy about art
Linklater was like this was stolen yeah
it was a giant lawsuit there's an art
Linklater know who was the guy that did
it art buchwald [ __ ] wall that's it art
buchwald
so I wonder what happens to they have to
credit him probably like with grateful
thanks to a book like that up and in the
Terminator Harlan Ellison sued James
Cameron over theft of the idea because
he had written a story called the
soldier I think yeah it was very similar
and there was a episode of the Outer
Limits that he wrote called demon with a
glass hand and so he sued and it it did
make the credits with the actual cut but
now if you watch the video it says with
thanks to the works of Harlan Ellison
he's tucked into the credits somewhere
and I'm sure we got paid so art buchwald
gonna get paid again but we're gonna get
to see more adventures with Hakeem I'm
all for that man
you there was no part of you that even
though I'd like my version of the movie
better I think yours is better but I'm
all for it yeah I'll take it
because I want Eddie Murphy to be funny
again he was the funniest man on the
planet for like ten years and then
decided not to be funny anymore yeah
like how do how do you turn that [ __ ]
off you know what just got bored me I
mean think about who's funny his whole
life as Ollie he stopped being funny
just stop being funny and movies and
[ __ ]
probably in real life he was like I'm
just as funny as I've ever been he's
like but now you know maybe I'll be
funny in a movie again
I'm all for it man I liked when he did
drama too but [ __ ] like this is a good
idea as soon as I saw this was like they
had my [ __ ] money
I want them to sequel eyes everything
keeps equalizing my entire childhood
until I [ __ ] drop dead that's all I
want small wishes yes that's it
[ __ ] that you'd never imagine come on
[ __ ] nobody [ __ ] ever thought this
was going to happen that's where we live
in a world of infinite wonderful
possibility like yeah the government's
[ __ ] weird but this is amazing and if
they want to keep distracting us with
like here's coming to America - I'll
forget all that [ __ ] bill like yeah show
me that [ __ ] again I'm ready man my
heart's open to this alright last thing
last piece of news listen to this but
just more remembrance I think okay
January 10th was the 20th anniversary of
Batman Beyond Wow
twenty years since that began yeah
that's it yeah I mean like good for them
I really enjoyed it I loved Kevin Conroy
taking the older Bruce Wayne role it
gave us one of the greatest episodes of
the Justice League cartoon where Amanda
Waller had to come back and tell Terry
McGinnis the story of Bruce Wayne and
his compassion with the Royal Flush gang
the girl ace it's a beautiful [ __ ]
moment yeah I I enjoyed it I didn't it
wasn't as important to me or as
meaningful to me of course as Batman the
Animated Series it asked me to get used
to a lot of new console
and you know I went with the most of the
weighing stuff but I still I love my
Batman but I absolutely respect the [ __ ]
out of Batman Beyond not the least of
which is thankfully it gave us a name
for our new podcast right now and
hopefully we'll get 20 [ __ ] years out
of the name you I do this is a live
action movie like today that's what I
was going to say yeah in a world where
into the spider-verse
manages to breathe fresh life into
spider-man which didn't need that much
force like to begin with I know they
were doing fine it's not like off is
fantastic yeah you know they've got
another one coming we're all excited but
it radically redefines what a spider-man
movie could be without forgetting any of
what came before true and I think that
if you're looking to there was an
animated feature and [ __ ] I would
totally do it that way or even his
live-action they should do it live back
I get [ __ ] Michael Keaton back as
Bruce Wayne what you just witnessed was
Mike um the face good job we didn't just
say [ __ ] that excites me that would be
[ __ ] amazing could you imagine oh my
god that movie makes a billion right
there man
you're like if Michael Keaton's come
back people like how is that possible
you're like because he's [ __ ] Batman
beyond bitchin people like oh [ __ ] we
wanted this our whole lives
this is [ __ ] good I'm down with this
here's my one can we go I don't know
well talk to Matt Reeves but I hey I
know you want to do like the Batman but
if you just did Batman Beyond if I'm
them right now like they're hot go for
it man show us another world think about
it like Batman Beyond allows you to show
an audience of world they haven't seen
yet just like Aquaman took us into the
oceans and showed us a quasi futuristic
[ __ ]
Batman beyond his all [ __ ] Blade
Runner you know come to life and [ __ ] so
take a Batman story and stick it in a
universe we've never seen with new
villains and [ __ ] that are variations
tell us a Batman origin that we haven't
heard 48 thousand times before exactly
and it's still connected to the Batman
you all know and love like there's Bruce
Wayne he's just old as [ __ ] and it's got
a dog
version man and it's tenders it's kind
of father-son story dynamic even if you
don't go that route and say they're
related and stuff it's still the mentor
training the mentee is that that what
you call what do you know you got an NT
minty-fresh
I'm all for it I hope they they make
this movie but nobody's talking about it
right now yeah they should though Warner
Brothers you should I mean don't talk to
them plead with James Wan he's the one
that's gonna get it done he's the guy
that like saw and a visionary version of
Aquaman and his vision included visions
of the past when I talked to him in San
Diego I was like who's first saw the
trailer I said [ __ ] Black Manta looks
like Black Manta and [ __ ] Aquaman
he's wearing in the Lego sculpture
inside he's got the orange shirt on what
the [ __ ] man why are you making [ __ ]
look like it looks in the comics and he
goes because these are classic designs
that if it stood the test of time for 50
years why change him like they work and
[ __ ]
give that guy Batman Beyond man that's
what I'd say
speaking of spider-verse they won a
Golden Globe they did Best Animated
Feature amazing give it up for
spider-verse a fantastic fantastic group
and like even though Aquaman has been
crushing everything in the [ __ ] box
office making a billion dollars into the
spider verse is very quietly made like
two hundred and seventy million dollars
world worldwide oh thank you
worldwide yeah what is it done here is
it cracked 100 yet 110 here
oh [ __ ] good for them man and again like
you would imagine like hey it's it's
spider-man
so it's pre-sold but everyone's pre-sold
on a spider-man movie people weren't
necessarily pre-sold on an animated
flick oh my god it was breathtaking
the only injustice of that Golden Globe
win is that it was just limited to Best
Animated Feature that easily could have
been the best feature of the year and
they got two categories in which they
could [ __ ] in those categories it was
that good I think it still stands as my
favorite movie of last year next week we
got another show when is it the 22nd so
ten days from now am I right about that
12 oh my god my math still holds when we
return we're gonna do our list
top ten list e 2018 all the stuff the
movies that we [ __ ] love mark wanted
to do it today but I didn't get to do my
list show so we'll wait until next I'm
sitting on it
but spider-verse you know spoilers
probably top of my list you spoilers I
don't know way to [ __ ] create a little
anticipation that all the news all the
news we have to sit there it is folks
mark brought you the news and the news
is gone
give it up a mark barnard now we come to
the other part of the show man the part
of the show where we open the questions
up to you folks we open and turn the
mics to the audience and do Q&A steez
man Zac you out there Zac right there
he's got a microphone and whatnot he's
gonna pick three people we're gonna
bring them right up here so that they
can catch you with this camera and they
could see at home if we like your
question and if it's relevant to both of
us that's the only thing we asked please
don't ask us questions you know that the
other one can also play a along with and
[ __ ] like that like don't ask me cab
what's it like to [ __ ] your wife mark
doesn't know unless he dies
so I keep it about stuff that we can
generally talk about together and stuff
but that being said sky's the limit
what's your name young camper Adam
everyone give it up or out of me
Adam is wearing a scum and villainy
Cantina t-shirt very stylish and [ __ ]
something I've neglected to mention at
the beginning of the show we are as
always right here at the scum and
villainy Cantina in Hollywood on
Hollywood Boulevard put your hands
together so the folks at home know
you're real better late than never
anyway over to you Adam what you got
well first of all Kevin hello and Mark
my wife was going to the bathroom when
you guys came out so she came was like
Kevin said hi to me okay so my question
for you guys is with a constant change
of like reboots and remakes we've
already heard that they would never make
up back to the future for so coming to
you guys Universal comes up to you guys
say mark and Kevin we want you guys to
reboot or remake the Back to the Future
franchise what is your guys's take on it
and who would you guys have for the real
roles at least of the three main which
is Biff Marty and Doc I I would I would
just basically count back 30 years from
where we are now and that would be the
past because that's what it would be I
wouldn't send him back to the 50s that'd
be [ __ ] weird
they'd be grandparents at the beginning
of the story and [ __ ]
which I guess is a way to do it and
stuff but essentially they'd go back to
like the 80s are coming close to the 90s
at this point who would I cast Marty
McFly
that's how I cash it oh no I don't know
who I would cast man I'm trying to think
whose who is Michael J Fox I mean nobody
could ever be Michael J Fox but who
isn't a Michael J Fox ish position yeah
but Tom Hollands like [ __ ] famous
that was my first instinct I was like
Tom Hollands it would be amazing and
stuff but also do we want like you know
I don't know shouldn't it be diverse
we've had a white Marty McFly SH and
we'd be looking elsewhere and stuff
Donald Glover Johnson is pretty white
but he's sure I guess you could be short
and diverse I don't know if you were
casting based on how they cast back to
the future
well first they cast Eric Stoltz and
then they replaced him with Michael J
Fox Michael J Fox was on family ties
which while not a number-one sitcom was
in the top ten if I remember correctly
it was if not the top 15 so you have to
if you're using that you look at what
sitcoms are around anymore in popular
and maybe work from there I just came
off the Goldberg so I would cast that
kid Troy who plays Barry Goldberg on the
show I think he's a [ __ ] genius he
reminds me of Jason Mewes man he's one
of the funner aspects of doing that show
because anything he says he can make
funny and sometimes he doesn't even know
that it's funny but he [ __ ] rocks it
it's amazing so I I don't know you got
ideas I mean I if you're stumping me
[ __ ] if Universal came to me and said I
want you to redo back to the future I
would say no yeah but this is a cybereye
like you better do it well shoot your
balls off I don't know if you know this
bill your balls are not up here
well that mark any special take or
different version you would do that I
mean I think if we're gonna have to play
the game anyway go ahead you have
we make it I think I think you're right
you don't go back to the 50s I think
maybe you go back to the 70s maybe you
go back to disco mm-hmm which feels as
oddly diverge from our current reality
as the 50s meant to the to the 80s I
think either Gaytan matarazzo the the
kid from stranger things with the
[ __ ] curly ass hair yeah that kid
could be interesting okay I think
zendaya could be really interesting as
Marty McFly oh the girl from from
homecoming Marty McFly I think you could
do that
you know that's a good [ __ ] idea cuz
suddenly it's just like I learnt a
different version a whole different
thing this time she's a girl and I think
there's also a world in which you get
[ __ ] Michael J Fox to play Doc Brown
in this particular universe
oh my god you almost made me cry I want
to see your version that's [ __ ] good
because we I mean it's [ __ ]
time-travel you and especially the
second movie explains to you multiverses
and now each time you go back in time
you're altering the way time goes and I
think you could totally make a world in
which Doc Brown is actually Michael J
Fox who or Marty McFly the OG Marty
McFly is a [ __ ] nuclear physicist who
invents time travel I like your movie
very very much who would you cast
besides endo we need a Biff yeah Biff
Nathan Jones
ah from Memex for your um [ __ ] what
the hell was his name
nicholas hoult also from the Mad Max
fury road what yeah the about a boy boy
the about a boy boy who's also he's away
abit I want to write a title shot Ian
Crouch Shh that's true he was that guy -
yeah beasts do an American accent yeah
Jason Mewes [ __ ] that was good man was a
great question you definitely win and
you know you win for that you are not
only winning season one of Castle Rock
written by Mark Bernard end but as you
sit there and watch it you're gonna
smoke weed out of a spoon pipe featuring
Bluntman and chronic from the good folks
at famous brands smoke them if you got
in my planner you win tickets to screen
X are they oh my god so we also Brett
Deacon our good friend Brett Teigen gave
us tickets to not 40x but what is this
green X screen X what about the one with
it [ __ ] they have the walls the walls
are another screen right so it becomes
as like 280° cinematic experience lots
and lots of screen lots and lots of so
you got all the screens at screen X
where is it I think there's one in
Koreatown there might be another one in
LA fantastic that's what you're winning
tonight man you winning tickets to
screen X go see any movie on a screen
that's all the way [ __ ] 180 160 181
it's [ __ ] like back here - all the
way around here obviously we don't know
anything about the technology but it
sounds really cool then there's also
Castle Rock season 1 and there's also a
Jay and Silent Bob pipe from famous
brands question number two is come from
this young man what's your name sir
Daniel everyone give it up for Daniel
[Applause]
like all things good give you a better
mic don't know this one
great alright so with the to piggyback
on the reboot thing you know all these
new fantastic sci-fi repos are coming
Star Trek Star Wars the one they just
did on Netflix when do you think we're
gonna get a Stargate reboot stargate
reboot it seems easy right to pull off I
was never big I saw the original
Stargate in the theater and then they
did a series which I never watched yeah
but clearly easy enough concept to pull
off yeah I mean static update I I don't
know I I was never a huge fan of the
series either I watched I think the
first season before they added an sg-1
or maybe after I can't remember yeah I
don't know man like it it feels it feels
as if it's ripe for a reboot that you
I'm thinking cinematic reboot where you
keep Kurt Russell as the grizzled
veteran going in good still totally work
that's right he was in the original yeah
I forgot yeah I don't know whether
there's right so I'm Jay Davidson on
that as well yeah dude from The Crying
Game
yeah I think that was like the last time
we saw Jay Davidson yeah but yeah I mean
I think you could make a reboot of it I
don't know if anybody is hungry for a
Stargate reboot I don't think it's gone
long enough not being an existence for
people to actually mount a real campaign
for it you know what I mean like we
haven't gone without it for long enough
and it's not quite like I mean [ __ ]
rocky we went long enough without a
Rocky movie to get creed and they did
but I also ended with rocky fire and
that was yeah you know so I think yeah
there's a world which it could happen I
mean [ __ ] it there's a world in which
you could have like a buckaroo banzai TV
show
but uh but there has to be that demand
for it I don't know if that demand is
there just yet but it could be you could
totally be here man I'm gonna call it I
guarantee you somewhere in town somebody
is developing the Stargate reboot you
know they had toys at one point like
it's pre-sold and and they will always
opt in favor of something known over
something that's unknown even if like 10
people knew it they're like hey man
that's somewhere to start with rather
than Ground Zero trying to tell people
what this new thing is so yeah I think
it'll it's not a matter of time before
we see some Stargate action I guess you
look anticipatory you're ready for it I
was I just like Kurt Russell so we all
do II won give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen take your booty pleasure my
friend birthday today whose what's your
name man my name is Chris what is it
Chris
everyone give it up for Chris like this
did I hear correctly it's your birthday
tonight it's correct the [ __ ] man how
old it 42 42 let's say how you look good
to you man you do look good on the count
of three Chris it is right yes here we
go happy birthday to Chris one two three
happy birthday happy birthday
to you Chris happy birthday dear
RunAs happy birthday to you welcome to
42 [ __ ] 42 is the answer to life
the universe and everything what is the
question yeah that's the problem that
was the problem mark I love that shirt
oh thank you so are you sure
very nice doing as Jaws jaws does a
question is I know you're gonna do your
28th recap next episode so I won't ask
you what your favorite season of TV was
this year but maybe your favorite
episode of television this year and what
you're looking most forward in 2019 let
me see what was your start with you I'll
try to think of what am i favorite
episode of television mine was the Queen
on Castle thank you that's yeah it's an
amazing episode if you haven't seen
Castle Rock it is an episode about [ __ ]
Spacek characters is playing a character
named Ruth Ruth Deaver and she has
dementia and so the episode is entirely
on her POV of what dementia is like for
her and for her it's like time travel in
that she can walk into a room and
suddenly she's in 1973 are walking into
that room and some she's in 1982 and she
does this thing where she takes chess
pieces and uses it to anchor herself and
the time she's supposed to be in if she
sees a chess piece she knows okay now
now I'm back in 2018 and so it's all
about her is kind of investigating her
own past and coming to terms with trauma
and tragedy and hope and dreams all
while it feeling like it's almost like
quantum leap ish in a way and it's
heartbreaking by the end of it because
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] Spacek and Scott
Glenn and it's about their romance in in
a town where bad things happen all the
time and it was written by a show where
Sam Shaw who when I started the show we
started a week late because his mother
had just died
of dementia and so more complications of
dementia and so he like that was that we
knew very early on is like no we're
doing this episode is gonna be about
this and I'm gonna write it because I
have things I need to say and it was
that process was helping him with just
ammunition just like what do you need
any anything you need for us from us as
the room we're happy to give it but we
know that this is going to be your
magnum opus this is going to be your
your your perfect crystal palace that
you're gonna build to break hearts which
he did and it's an amazing episode of TV
it really is I'm trying to think of a TV
episode this year that I saw that
affected me quite that much and I and
they I can I can tell you this show that
I love the most which might be easier
the good place the good place is this
remarkable combination of science
fiction and metaphysics and just
out-and-out [ __ ] comedy and there is
not a weak link in that cast and it's
smarter than any other show on TV and
the thing that I love about is every
season it becomes a fundamentally
different show like the first season is
how did I end up in a good place and
then spoiler alert the end of the first
season said no you're not in the good
place in the bad place and then it
becomes why am I in the bad place and
then it resets itself every year and it
becomes something else totally different
and I it is it is embarrassing to watch
a show be that good and realize that you
are not also that good cuz ya know it's
it's amazing if you're not watching it
you should because it's maybe the best
show on TV definitely the best Network
show on TV I don't know but my favorite
moment where I don't even know it's my
favorite but it's a moment that is
really stuck with me and I'd still don't
know why was in the HBO show succession
it was about ten episode series in I
think it was the final episode one of
the main characters does something
pretty heinous and like gets away with
it
and slips back into a party it's a
wedding and in the wedding they're
playing the Whitney Houston song I want
to dance with somebody and the dude he's
estranged from his family's divorced
from his wife he's got kids with her
instead he winds up dancing with him he
like gets back to the wedding
nobody's aware of what he did while he
was off premises and his ex-wife like
waves him over where she's dancing with
the kids and he has this moment of
absolute bliss dancing to this leg
totally [ __ ] fun Whitney Houston song
where the character for one brief moment
is like safe and who he wants to be and
this would be amazing if this was life
but life is about to intrude in a big
[ __ ] bad way like ten minutes after
this I found it fascinating how though
it was a really well-played moment and
it was mostly just the actors faces
wordless dialogue in his well-played
scene and well-written scene but the
actor whose name escapes me
he was dude that was in the big shirt he
was the main character the main son in
succession really [ __ ] pulled it off
just a magical moment about something
very dark but something very human like
this dude is never going to have
normalcy and for one [ __ ] moment he's
dancing at a dopey wedding with his wife
and kids the way anybody else would was
kind of kind of I'm not stuck with me
alright so there was that moment but I
can't I can't think of I can tell you
about two things I watched recently
which I did love and they weren't series
though I saw assasin a shin nation
I bought that on iTunes and watched it
and I was one of those movies where I
was like [ __ ] man I got to step up my
game is insanely well-made insanely well
shot ideas that communicate you know
with the current generation made me feel
old and that's a good thing and a bad
thing at the same time
really well made I enjoyed the [ __ ] out
of it couldn't turn it off was riveted
and then what was the second thing I
watch sorry to bother you did you see
this yeah yeah that's a great movie it's
wonderful just absolutely breathtaking
high wire indie film act with great
performances across the board Tessa
Thompson continues to be I think one of
my favorite actresses on the planet
everything she's in she's just so [ __ ]
winning and stuff and I watch Creed -
did you see creatures did eleventeen
Cree - it's it's it's it's the sequel
there's absolutely nothing wrong with it
it's totally entertaining but it's it's
weird like it feels like now like people
don't really do sequels anymore they
keep a story going and [ __ ] and it's
like this is the new chapter and whatnot
and it's the follow-up movie isn't
really like technically a sequel like
we're taking the ideas and the villains
just doing it again Creed - kind of felt
like that like he's having another fight
like that's the whole plot and the fact
that he fights Drago's kid is what makes
it kind of like oh that's why I like
this fight but it felt like a sequel
like that was they didn't break insanely
new ground but I was entertained the
whole way
I love the plot device I love that they
have one foot spoilers there's some
spoilers they even brought back Brigitte
Nielsen Wow
that was I was watching the movie going
somebody gives a [ __ ] man like somebody
really cared enough to be like call up
Brigitte Nielsen then I probably had to
be sylvester stallone they used to be
involved it sent me down a rabbit hole
where I was like weren't they a couple
and [ __ ] and I was like how did this
happen like I was so involved with it so
it's definitely worth watching but
Michael Jordan looks [ __ ] amazing
it's it's the only I was watching the
movie hilt I'm going like that's that is
humanly possible because he's also a
human and he's done this I can't do that
but I could because I see that it's
humanly possible but I'm like yeah but
only if you're superhuman or if that is
your entire job for like four months
is to wake up and eat and train
and maybe take a nap and eat and train
and eat and sleep and rinse and repeat
and that's what that does does for like
to look like that
did you ever see on Twitter I see every
once in a while like you know for you go
to the main top stories or whatever [ __ ]
you know they'll put like under it a
bunch of tweets of people you don't
follow and [ __ ] but like they'll do in
my groupings it's like because you like
comic book tweets or some comic book
people because you like comedians here's
some communities because you've liked
Marvel movies here's Chris Hemsworth and
I love Chris Hemsworth the actor and
whatnot but I would never put him in my
timeline because he would make me feel
bad every day because he's constantly
[ __ ] posting workout videos and he
posted this one video where he's like
out in the [ __ ] public park and he's
doing this like absolutely grueling
looking squat thrusts thing where you're
twisting from side to side if I'd done
one I'd be like my back and just gone
the [ __ ] out and he's like you know
starting 2019 the right way and I'm like
[ __ ] you Thor like wait did we cover
everything you did we did you win [ __ ]
for your birthday you know what we got
one more thing one more thing you also
get to DX tickets for every six what do
you get there do we do it one more time
all right pick someone out Zach give it
up for careers man you're giving tickets
I don't need them it's okay take it to
the X experience how are you doing
I understand you've ruff holiday I
really did in the Dobson [ __ ] we'll get
out of it this will pull you out of it a
Bluntman and chronic rolling tray house
of the good folks at famous brands it'll
be pure green in four days
totally what can we do you for um I was
going to ask sorry I'm in the wrong spot
now you're in the absolutely right okay
how come with you know every time
anybody asks you guys questions you keep
coming up with male names for who can
direct this or that have you guys
thought about female directors or their
place or even just female parts you know
off-screen more I know you're doing a
women and film thing coming up but how
can we change that where you don't just
think of you know Ridley Scott or James
Cameron for these movies so damn true
yeah I'm hardwired to always be like who
this person this person should oddly
enough I'm never hardwired to be like me
as a director I'll reference other
people and stuff but yeah you're right
it's I guess because most of my life the
directors have been predominantly male
that's changing though right now which
is great so I yeah it's a matter of
retraining I guess and starting to go
like okay you know now it's very easy to
be like oh well patty Jenkins could do
it name another I know that's the
problem it's just like well I'm Lexi
Alexander has always been like somebody
that I champion just because I saw her
partnership flick and was like Jesus
Christ man like this is hands-down one
of the best action movies I've ever seen
you know I could go fancy and say Jane
Campion because I love the piano let me
see then it starts getting hard I was
maybe eight nine months ago or so when
when Kathleen Kennedy announced that she
was giving the game of thrones guys
trilogy in Star Wars trilogy that get
out before the trilogy and it was like
yeah okay I get it Benioff and Weiss
sure they just a game of Thrones they're
amazing storytellers I get it I totally
get it but I also couldn't help but
wonder like and this is part of a larger
conversation about who gets to tell Star
Wars stories right and if you look if
you grind the numbers and you look at
everybody who's made a Star Wars movie
every
but he credited above-the-line writer
director producer in a Star Wars movie
there is aside from Kathleen Kennedy
there was one name that is not a white
dude and it's Leigh Brackett who
co-wrote Empire Strikes Back and so for
30 years we have seen one particular
version of that story and some of them
are great some of them are not whatever
however you feel about it but it's we've
been looking through that monocle and so
I kind of went on Twitter and I'm like
listen some of these are great and that
decision makes all the sense in the
world in a vacuum but larger than that
who gets to tell these stories don't
tell me that let's Shonda Rhimes as
another Star Wars story she wants to
tell Ava doesn't have one Karyn Kusama
doesn't have one Jane Campion doesn't
have one
Cheryl dunyah doesn't have one patty
Jenkins doesn't have one there's a huge
vast [ __ ] list if it Mahoney doesn't
have one there's a ton of female
directors out there
who I'm sure like maybe like science
fiction maybe don't but if you said you
can I have a Star Wars movie they'd find
one they'd find one to tell and so yes
there there there are far too many women
female directors who are not getting the
boost that they should and some of it is
like you have said it's just you know we
had been trained for so long especially
coming up in the 70s 80s and 90s where
most of the great directors most of the
fetishization about directors was your
Scorsese's and your De Palma's and your
Woody Allen and also let's be honest -
like yeah it seems to be very
male-dominated but it's just this is a
business that's like hey did that person
make a movie that made money get that
person again
so if you can keep a streak going you're
you know you'll always get to [ __ ]
called furthermore - man working there
were women and there was some stat
saying that female directors take like
200% longer between first movie and
second movie to get that one made it was
something like eight years between
monster and Wonder Woman for patty
Jenkins she done some TV though she
doesn't TV but like monsters a great
movie one shot least they're in an Oscar
yeah and one one's a great movie it you
know probably will win like especially
especially Fox it just went on a Marvel
movie and then like off it or some of
the pages she was she was on for the
dark world for a dark world
but it's just there for some reason and
you know it's a systemic reason but it
takes longer for women to get that
second job to get that second shot
because it's seen as a risk can she pull
it off I don't know of course you can
pull it off she's a [ __ ] director
yeah you know but and the mindset is
beginning to change and those second
chances are coming faster for people and
we're now at a point where if you say
like hey I want to sell this movie who's
gonna direct it you say Ava that movie's
gonna get made you know in a way that
doesn't apply for like 90% of the male
directors working you know like it's
it's shifting slowly gently maybe needs
to be more forcefully but it's shifting
and to be able to summon to mind you
know a dozen female directors who can
make a Star Wars movie is something to
work towards I think for the industry as
well as for me even the guardians -
right if they're looking for a director
for that galaxy 3 3 sorry Michelle
Maclaren could direct the [ __ ] out of
guardians 3 or Rachel Talalay who does
like phenomenal job like almost every
other week on flash and yeah Doctor Who
on all the CW stuff that Doctor Who and
you know was that this comic book movie
stuff long before anyone else when she
made Tank Girl yeah I'm all for it
believe me I'm trying to take the jobs I
don't want they should given the people
who are passionate about them and I
guarantee you there are a bunch of women
out there way passionate about playing
with these toys just as much as the big
boys but I'm believe me I'm not in
anybody's way it's just hard for me to
come up with names but I got to retrain
myself to do that because that's a lot
of the TV i watch winds up being
directed by women all the time
so yeah that's something I'll work on in
2019 thank you hey man you win a tray
and tickets County
excellent senior alright we've answered
questions we've given out [ __ ] we've
talked about the news
is there anything possible left to
discuss
I mean world peace but we won't fix that
now perhaps next episode I it's been how
long since we did this two months all
[ __ ] holiday long I was like [ __ ] I
can't wait and stuff it was nice to come
home and do this surround it with y'all
ladies and gentlemen have you had a good
time this afternoon I cannot thank you
enough for coming out and joining us
here at the scum and villainy Cantina
but let's be honest there is no show
without the smart one give it up to the
for the man to my left mr. Marc [ __ ]
burn Arden WT a nominated Marvin Arden
and that is fat man I'm Batman for this
week I'm Kevin Smith Sam and beyond for
this walk i know i it's it's been a
minute and it's staring me right that is
batman beyond for this week man I'm
Kevin Smith mark Bernardo tune in next
time same fat same fat channel SModcast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith go
beyond ladies gentlemen good
[Applause]